♪ ♪
>> THE IRAN DEAL WAS ONE OF THE
WORST AND MOST ONE-SIDED
TRANSACTIONS THE UNITED STATES
HAS EVER ENTERED.
IN THE EVENT WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
REACH A SOLUTION WORKING WITH
CONGRESS AND OUR ALLIES, THEN
THE AGREEMENT WILL BE
TERMINATED.
>> WHAT IS THE WORST-CASE
SCENARIO?
OR PLAN B?
>> MY POINT IS TO SAY DON'T
LEAVE NOW.
AS LONG AS YOU NOT HAVE A BETTER
OPTION FOR NUCLEAR.
>> IT WOULD BE A BAD PRECEDENT
IF THE UNITED STATES SENDS THIS
MESSAGE TO THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY THAT THE LENGTH OR
DURATION OF ANY AGREEMENT WOULD
DEPEND ON THE DURATION OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> Bret: TALKING ABOUT THE
IRAN DEAL.
THAT WILL BE TALK BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT MACRON WHO ARRIVED
HERE IN WASHINGTON TODAY.
ALSO ARRIVING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IT CAME IN AT JOINT BASE ANDREWS
WITH HIS WIFE THERE.
AND THEN ARRIVED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR TALKS WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY, THE TWO
COUPLES, TOGETHER AT
MOUNT VERNON IN THE HISTORIC
GEORGE WASHINGTON HOMESTEAD
HAVING A DINNER TONIGHT BEFORE
THE OFFICIAL STATE DINNER
TOMORROW.
WHAT ABOUT THIS IN FOREIGN
POLICY NEWS?
STEVE HAYES, EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
"THE WEEKLY STANDARD" ."
DAN BALZ, "WASHINGTON POST."
CHARLIE HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
DAN, IT'S A BIG VISIT.
OBVIOUSLY THE FIRST STATE VISIT,
OFFICIAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK BOTH SIDES ARE
LOOKING FOR?
>> I THINK CLEARLY
PRESIDENT MACRON HAS COME ON A
MISSION TO TRY TO TALK THE
PRESIDENT INTO STAYING IN THE
IRAN AGREEMENT.
THE EUROPEANS ARE VERY MUCH
ALARMED THAT THE PRESIDENT COULD
PULL OUT OF IT.
HE HAS SIGNALED HE IS LIKELY
TOO.
MAY 12 IS THE DEADLINE IN WHICH
HE HAS TO RECERTIFY THE
AGREEMENT OR DECIDE TO PULL OUT
OF IT.
WE KNOW THAT THE TEAM THAT USED
TO BE AROUND HIM KEPT HIM FROM
DOING THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE NEW TEAM
IS GOING TO ADD UP.
MACRON IS HERE TO ARGUE THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO WORK OUT SOME
ARRANGEMENTS AND AGREEMENTS THAT
WILL SATISFY THE PRESIDENT'S
CONCERNS AND KEEP HIM IN IT.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THAT'S
POSSIBLE?
>> I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN PUSHING A PLAN IN BILATERAL
DISCUSSIONS WITH GREAT BRITAIN,
GERMANY, AND FRANCE SEEKING TO
STAY IN THE DEAL, TO CALL IN FOR
ADDITIONAL SNAP INSPECTIONS OF
MILITARY SITES, ADDITIONAL
SANCTIONS, SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE A BITE WITH IRANIAN
NONCOMPLIANCE.
IT'S BEEN UNDER DISCUSSION FOR
SIX WEEKS, MAYBE LONGER.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER GERMANY
WILL AGREE TO IT.
FRANCE HAS BEEN PUSHING.
FRANCE AND THE UNITED STATES OR
IN A SIMILAR POSITION ON THIS
STUFF.
GREAT BRITAIN IS A LITTLE
HARDER.
GERMANY HAS REALLY BEEN
DIFFICULT.
I WOULD IMAGINE PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND MACRON WILL SPEND SOME TIME
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO GET GERMANY
ABOARD THE PLAN.
EVEN IF RUSSIA HAS DECLARED THEY
WON'T BE PART OF ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THE EXISTING DEAL.
>> Bret: CHARLIE.
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING
SITUATION.
MACRON HAS, IS WORKING WELL WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
HE HAS FIGURED OUT IF YOU LISTEN
CAREFULLY TO WHAT HE SAYS AND
IGNORE SOME OF THE UNUSUAL, THE
IMPOLITIC STYLE OF THINGS
DONALD TRUMP DOES, THAT YOU CAN
GET SOMEWHERE WITH THEM.
ONE OF THE THINGS I ADMIRE ABOUT
WHAT TRUMP HAS DONE HERE IS
OBVIOUSLY HE CAMPAIGNED ON THE
PROMISE THAT HE WAS GOING TO
TEAR THIS THING UP ON DAY ONE.
HE HASN'T YET.
HE WAS PREVENTED, TALK OF DOING
IT.
YET AGAIN, LOOKING AT THE
SITUATION WHERE DONALD TRUMP HAS
MULTIPLIED THE MOVING PARTS,
WHETHER IT'S WITH TARIFFS,
WHETHER IT'S WITH THE
NEGOTIATIONS IN NORTH KOREA.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF MOVING PARTS.
THERE'S A LOT MORE WAYS OF
CUTTING THE PIE AND GETTING
DEALS THAT SATISFY EVERYBODY AT
THE TABLE.
AND I IMAGINE THAT'S PROBABLY
WHAT THEY WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
TONIGHT AT MOUNT VERNON.
ABOUT THE IRAN DEAL, THERE'S A
DIFFERENT GROUP AROUND HIM.
>> Bret: JOHN BOLTON OPPOSED
TO THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
POMPEO IS OPPOSED TO THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
I HAVE PRESSED HIM ON EYE.
HE SAYS HE FINDS ZERO
BENEFICIAL.
NOW HE'S MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
NOMINATION.
SPEAK ABOUT THAT, THE FACT THAT
THERE WAS THIS POLITICAL PROCESS
DURING THE SHOW.
CHRIS COONS VOTED PRESENT,
ENABLES A FAVORABLE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON THE FLOOR WHERE HE
WILL HAVE THE VOTES.
>> HE WILL BE THE NEXT SECRETARY
OF STATE AND HE HAS THE
PRESIDENT'S EAR AND AWAY
SECRETARY TILLERSON NEVER DID.
HE'S EARNED A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PRESIDENT THROUGH HOURS
SPENT DOING THE DAILY BRIEFING
ON OTHER THINGS.
HE SPENT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY TRUSTS
HIM.
I THINK ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS, THERE WAS A LITTLE
EQUIVOCATION IN HIS CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS ABOUT THE IRAN DEAL
WHICH SUGGESTED HE MAY NOT BE
QUITE WHERE HE WAS EARLIER ON
THIS.
I THINK IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
EXACTLY HOW IT WILL COME OUT.
BUT WE KNOW HE AND BOLTON HAVE
BEEN MUCH MORE HOSTILE TO THIS
AGREEMENT THEN PRIOR TEAM.
>> Bret: WHILE WE WERE
TALKING, WE GOT THE VIDEO AND
FOR MOUNT VERNON OF THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT AND THE PRESIDENT
MEETING THERE.
THEY PLANTED A TREE THAT
PRESIDENT MACRON BROUGHT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THEY TOOK A
HELICOPTER RIDE, MARINE ONE,
AROUND THE MONUMENTS IN
WASHINGTON.
AND THEN HERE, THEY ARE ARRIVING
AT MOUNT VERNON, AND HE'S
OBVIOUSLY GIVING A LITTLE
INSTRUCTIONAL ABOUT MOUNT VERNON
THERE TO THE FRENCH PRESIDENT.
THEY WILL HAVE DINNER TOGETHER,
THE TWO COUPLES, BEFORE THE BIG
O OFFICIAL DINNER TOMORROW
NIGHT.
IT'S AMAZING TO SEE THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S DEVELOPED
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S VISIT TO
PARIS.
>> YOU REMEMBER THE HANDSHAKE.
ALL OF THE SCUTTLEBUTT THAT
SURROUNDED THAT.
REALLY INTERESTING INTERVIEW
WITH MACRON YESTERDAY BY
CHRIS WALLACE, MAKING SOME NEWS
I THINK ON A COUPLE DIFFERENT
FRONTS.
I THINK CHARLIE IS RIGHT.
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO
DONALD TRUMP AND UNDERSTAND HOW
TO PLAY THE PRESIDENT CAN LEAD
TO APPEAL TO THE PLACES WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEEDS APPEALING,
IN MUCH THE WAY SOME REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS HAVE DONE.
I THINK IT KEEPS HIS CRITICISM
PRIVATE.
HE DOESN'T TAKE SHOTS AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE'S GOT A DIFFICULT BALANCE TO
STRIKE.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT POPULAR IN
FRANCE.
NOT POPULAR IN WESTERN EUROPE
GENERALLY PRETTY HAS TO BE
CAREFUL NOT TO SEEM LIKE HE'S
BEING A TOADY TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AT THE SAME TIME, OR BOASTING
ABOUT HIS SUCCESS IN PERSUADING
HIM ON SYRIA FOR INSTANCE.
AT THE SAME TIME, APPEALING TO
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: LET ME PLAY THE
SOUND BITE FROM MACRON ON SYRIA.
>> WILL HAVE TO -- THE WAR
AGAINST ISIS.
FROM UP LITTLE POINT OF VIEW, IF
WE LEAVE THE FLOOR TO THE
IRANIAN REGIME, BASHAR AL-ASSAD.
THEY WILL PREPARE A NEW WAR.
>> Bret: HOW MUCH INFLUENCE HE
HAS OVER TRUMP FOREIGN POLICY.
>> I THINK THAT WAS A MISTAKE
FOR HIM TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT REBUILDING
SYRIA.
YOU OUGHT TO GET PEOPLE RUNNING
FOR THE HILLS.
TALKING ABOUT KILLING ISIS AND
DESTROYING ISIS?
THAT'S MORE APPEALING.
I DO THINK IT SORT OF A NICE
MOMENT TO REFLECT.
YOU HAVE THE FRENCH PRESIDENT.
AMERICAN PRESIDENT AT
MOUNT VERNON TODAY.
TRULY AMAZING THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED, WHETHER IT IS
ROCHAMBEAU AND